arjan I wanted to open up by talking a
little bit about the introduction to
your book so you write about this
collapse that you suffered that really
made you reevaluate your life your
priorities and I'm curious how
mindfulness came out of that because you
write a lot about health sleep exercise
and you could have very well you know
taking a vacation gotten some sleep and
then moved on why did you decide to stop
and focus on mindfulness as well for me
this collapse eight years ago when I
collapsed literally from burnout sleep
deprivation exhaustion hit my head on my
desk broke my cheekbone and found myself
coming to in a pool of blood of my own
eye that at that moment really made me
re-evaluate a lot of my life and in the
course of my life I had always been
interested in mindfulness in meditation
my mother taught me to meditate when I
was 13 living in Athens Greece that was
quite exceptional at the time I went to
Indian style comparative religion before
I went to college I've meditated on and
off all my life so I've always been
drawn to that aspect of life what
changed
eight years ago is that I realized that
I didn't want these to be sort of
episodic journeys but to integrate them
into my life on a daily basis and I
studied the science which is pretty
incontrovertible and and then I became
fascinated with how despite all that we
know scientifically behaviorally how
hard it is for us to still change and
that's really a big part of thrive that
how can we move from knowing what is
best for us to actually doing what is
best for us and to realize there are no
trade-offs between leading and effective
life we were to produce results and and
get stuff done and also being mindful
and
and taking care of that deeper dimension
of ourselves so when we talk about
mindfulness today how would you describe
its main tenets so what do we mean when
we say we need our lives to be more
mindful I love actually what Jon
kabat-zinn has said about mindfulness
which is that it's really hard fulness
as well as mindfulness it's really being
fully present each moment of our lives
mind and heart and body of course and
what follows is the recognition that
thoughts are going to come you know
we're not going to stop our thoughts but
we don't really have to follow them
wherever they go and that's where for me
breathing and consciously inhaling and
exhaling and is such an essential part
of mindfulness because I use my breath
to return to that central place in us
and let the thoughts come and go instead
of following every thought sort of
slavish ly wherever it wants to go the
other thing is that has been as you know
this avalanche of new scientific
discoveries that have validated ancient
wisdom so philosophers and spiritual
teachers have always known these things
but now have modern science validating
them and for me some of the most
important work is very to Davidson at
the University of Wisconsin who has
actually used modern methods like MRIs
and lasers on the brains of Buddhist
monks who've meditated for years to see
some incredible results on the brain
itself you know on gamma waves that show
how that the plasticity of the brain is
extraordinary and we can actually affect
how our brain functions by being more
mindful and taking time to meditate and
doing all these things in your book you
you refer a lot to Steve Jobs as kind of
someone who really took this to her
and managed to you know put good things
like mindfulness ahead of other things
that people normally link to success and
ended up succeeding more so than almost
anyone else in your mind is it possible
to achieve that kind of success we can
call jobs a genius if you want without
mindfulness is it actually an essential
component or is it something that you
can take or leave oh I think geniuses
are so rare that I'm sure there are many
ways to be a genius you know by
definition it does not conform to a
standard deviation so I'm talking about
all of us you know the rest of us who
are not certified geniuses what makes
for a life that is both more meaningful
and and more effective I like to use
that word because we all want to be
effective at whatever we are doing for
the vast majority of people we know for
certain that mindfulness enhances
everything it enhances performance and
there is no trade-off between being
mindful and being effective it also
enhances our own experience of life
because if we just define life purely in
terms of success reduced to these two
metrics of money and power we are
missing out on what for me is the
essence of life which you cannot really
experience without the third metric
which is like the third leg of the stool
in thrive I I define it as consisting of
these four pillars well-being wisdom
wonder and giving and that really what a
complete life is and very often we've
seen people who reach a level of success
and then begin to integrate giving or
wander by then it may be too late to
integrate well-being because we now know
that all that
have an immune system take if we live in
ways that are consistently stressful and
wisdom which has to do with decision
making again I quote a lot of people in
the book acknowledging like Bill Clinton
who said that the most important
mistakes are made I made when I was
tired so the connection between
exhaustion sleep deprivation etc and bad
decisions is huge
you